at the big talking point of the morning
it's like breastfeeding this about
Braille fees mothers who choose to take
pictures of themselves breastfeeding and
it's caused a bit of division between
moms who feel intimidated by this and
and can't actually do it or don't want
to do it but this layer they add
together with our doctor dr. Mohammed
Suri is Denise Sumpter and Denise
breastfeeds her daughter yes absolutely
that's okay what is unusual is that your
daughter is hi old seven she is seven
not only are you breastfeeding your
daughter at seven you've got a son Bo
who will see here we'll see these
pictures here and who is two so you have
cut it coming at all angles from you
basically huh hydrating is this for you
not at all I am breastfeeding once you
get used to it it's supply and demand
it's pretty easy and you know so I mean
no special effort particularly or you
know huge amounts of calories required I
mean you know yeah it's it's its usual
thing your body adapts to breastfeeding
yes no that's the usual thing what may
be deemed as unusual of course is the
fact that that Bell is seven years of
age
how do you do this must restrict you and
what you can do during the day and what
effect do you think it has on Bell um
not really it doesn't restrict me at all
and breastfeeding a seven-year-old is
very different from breastfeeding a
newborn or indeed a child of one or two
or four because when you don't forcibly
win your child when you let them we
naturally it's a very gradual slow thing
so for instance she may ask for milk
once a week or she may ask twice a day
but it's you know two minutes here and
there it's just a relaxing thing that
you didn't relax evening I'm really
interested in that Denise or as some
children may say mommy can I have a
yogurt or a chocolate bar or whatever
you think this is a comfy cozy bonding
type thing between you two it definitely
is but it's um I think you're wrong to
compare it to food because it's a lot of
press things a lot more than that as we
know you can't replace breastfeeding
with something to eat or something to
drink because when you breastfeed your
child you're giving them immune
benefits you're giving them oxytocin
you're giving them bonding you're giving
them proven psychological benefits if
you know there's a new study of Brazil
study that showed a long-term 6,000
people that those children now that's
starting the study are 30 years old and
they know with a direct correlation
between how long you breastfeed that
child and how successful and intelligent
they are in their adult life well your
bails going to be a super pre end of the
strip she wants to be a pop star and she
says that's people long enough
I'm bouncing like bunnies sing better
that's right and let's bring in the
doctor not at this stage and Deniz and
she obviously takes this completely in
her stride she believes this is very
very natural for her perform usually she
I think you are quite unusual because
most people are unable to sort of
maintain breastfeeding of any sort
whether it's you know for young children
or a little bit older child or older
infants for a long period of time
you're quite right there are so many
health benefits both for you and for
your child in breastfeeding but I
suppose the thing that's unusual of
course it's more culturally unusual for
us to breastfeed for later until later
in life while see historically we've
we've breastfed our children for much
longer
yeah because there's more of a need for
and there wasn't really an alternative
but now we do it much less than we used
to
can I can I respond to them um well can
I just say yeah you're quite right and
people that you say people can't
breastfeed for much longer actually you
know that's not quite right people can
recipe the problem is of course they
don't get the correct support and
culturally it's not a thing that's 100%
acceptable so you know that's
problematic Alana Isabel has this ahead
of her okay I've host our first assign
oh you've said Denise that you will only
stop breastfeeding your children when
they are stop asking you for a final yes
if they never stop asking when will you
draw the line right well the thing there
is we know that there aren't really any
teenagers or adults that actually
breastfeed we know um with George
evelopment and as the Emir the immune
system becomes a standalone thing in 212
up until they're teaming I have no idea
the
the average upper age if the unfit
anthropologically the studies say round
about eight so of course there are going
to be people that go beyond that average
and I know some personally and when you
say unusual actually I know hundreds of
thousands of people are online you know
in various groups who breastfeed their
children and Denise Mike will they'll
decide this do you think or you you
think bel will decide this um ah to
start though will decide bel will decide
yeah see cuz there could be a worried
that you're keeping her like a baby
almost I do I think if I think you'll
find if you know my daughter she is so
confident and so um you know she is very
independent and most of the time she's
like no mommy I know what I'm doing
leave me to get on with whatever it is
so well fascinating talking to you thank
you very much indeed that's Denise
Sumpter and she still breast feeds her
seven-year-old child
thank you very much need for talking to
us thank you very much